elliot page admits he was not okay after
his breakout role in 2007's juno
are you ashamed that we did it
no because at least you don't have to
have the evidence under your sweater
elliot looks incredible as the cover
star for esquire magazine summer issue
inside the actor reveals after the
success of the teen pregnancy flick the
pressure to discuss the film at splashy
industry events literally did almost
kill me quote i was closeted dressed in
heels and the whole look i wasn't okay
and i didn't know how to talk about that
with anyone
elliot recalls a specific instance while
promoting juno at the toronto
international film festival elliott says
his manager told him to put on a dress
for the red carpet but his co-star
michael sarah was in slacks and sneakers
quote i've had people who apologize
about things sorry i didn't know i
didn't know at the time it doesn't
matter if i'm trans or cis lots of cis
women dress how i dress the pressure to
live up to gender expectations is a
feeling elliot says was far too familiar
in his early to mid 20s the actor
explains he didn't know how to tell
people how unwell he was at the time i
was
i i
was acting too so
going to set every day and and changing
into clothes that you know
really made me feel ill elliott who's
been open about his battle with body
dysmorphia adds i struggled with food
intense depression anxiety severe panic
attacks i couldn't function i collapsed
and that was something that's happened
frequently in my life usually
corresponding with a panic attack the
canadian star got candid with oprah just
months after coming out as trans
revealing how a 2010 incident while
promoting inception took a toll on his
mental health i already had to wear the
dress had one picked out and i went in
and there were three dresses laid out
like new dresses to maybe see and i
just like
i like i lost it like i got so
it was like a cinematic moment you know
like the kind of like
thing that would be in a movie where you
know
and
that night after the premiere and at the
after party i collapsed and the emotions
continue as elliott reflected on how
much pride he feels after transitioning
i'm not having the moment where i'm
panicked
i'm not having all these little moments
that used to be
[Music]
just being in a t-shirt it's
being able to
touch my chest and
um
feel comfortable in my body for the
probably the first time
tears of joy
[Music]
you